horrible incident yesterday that many of
you have no doubt already heard about a
29 year old man from Uzbekistan rented a
flatbed pickup truck painted as a home
depot truck it's believed that it was an
actual Home Depot rental truck at this
time in New York City actually rented it
in New Jersey drove over into New York
City and down the West Side Highway and
into pedestrians on West Street in lower
Manhattan now West Street at that part
of Manhattan is the name of the West
Side Highway which is also known as
route 9a in New York City and when you
think about the shape of Manhattan it's
sort of narrow and long north the south
on the east side of the island
you have the FDR which is the sort of
north-south highway that exists there on
the west side you have the West Side
Highway and there's this really nice
bike path and running path alongside the
West Side Highway I know it well when
the David Pakman show was in New York
City our office was not too far from
this part and that's where the truck
veered off and into the bike path and
started to run people over and the use
of a truck to run people over has been a
mode employed by the sort of neo jihadi
Isis umbrella term terrorists over the
last couple of years but if there was
any doubt as to the ideological
background of this individual he
reportedly shouted Allahu Akbar god is
great in Arabic according to multiple
witnesses including both civilians and
law-enforcement officials when he was
exiting his truck now he exited the
truck with some people are describing
them as fake guns IB they were real guns
but it was a paintball gun and a pellet
gun so they were not real in the sense
that they did not fire what we would
call full ammunition full power
ammunition they were they were able to
fire paintballs and pellets and then the
driver shot by police and arrested
brought into surgery at Bellevue
Hospital in New York City out of surgery
FBI saying earlier today that they've
already interviewed the individual not
willing to say anything about the
content of those interviews at those at
this time and by all likely assessments
is going to spend the rest of his life
in prison now as far as the victims ate
people were killed total and I found out
that five were from my home country of
Argentina it was actually a group of
five Argentinians who came to the United
States to New York City to celebrate a
30th anniversary of high school
graduation so as you would imagine
people who graduated high school 30
years ago in their late 40s at this time
another report said that the sixth
non-american victim was a Belgian woman
later the report said that it was a
German individual I guess we're not a
hundred percent sure at this time or at
least I'm not a hundred percent sure and
as you can imagine Argentinian news
which I watch every day in the morning
has been covering this extensively I've
been receiving notices from the
Argentinean consulate in New York City
they've been working to be in touch with
family members of the five Argentinean
deceased individuals working to figure
out how to get the remains back to
Argentina as quickly as possible but in
concert with the wishes of the families
and then other than the eight killed
also eleven injured including two kids
maybe 12 injured I've seen both numbers
the kids at least reportedly not
seriously hurt some of the adults very
seriously hurt
and now the the fallout of this
politically starts to happen and Donald
Trump using this in a totally sort of
confusing way in a disappointing way in
a disjointed and confused way putting
out a couple of tweets about this
incident starting first by saying and
see if you can understand what what he's
saying here we must not allow my sis to
return or enter our country after
defeating them in the Middle East and
elsewhere enough so right away this is
an attempt to brag about his so-called
defeat of Isis which by the way is no
big thing to brag about I've been saying
for years at this point that more than
likely within two years within 18 to 24
months Isis in terms of its stronghold
in the Middle East is going to be
effectively destroyed whether it's Trump
Obama Ted Cruz Hillary whoever it is
that's in power that's the direction
things have been going but the more
difficult thing is going to be to root
out these individual attacks around the
world
sort of under the umbrella of Isis
ideology and it's also fine to say well
we're not going to let bad people people
who want to do damage and bad things to
the u.s. into the country but remember
that this is an individual who came to
the United States legally from
Uzbekistan and Uzbekistan is not on
Trump's or anybody else's travel ban
list nor have I heard anyone even
suggest that whose Bekaa stands should
be on the list so right away it's this
it's an attempt to politicize from
Donald Trump without it actually being
totally clear that he even understands
what's going on and then sadly in the
midst of all this Donald Trump putting
out another tweet about visas saying the
terrorists came into our country through
what's called the diversity Visa Lottery
program a Chuck Schumer beauty I want
merit-based and then also tweeting about
vetting I have just ordered homeland
security to step up our already extreme
vetting program being politically
correct it's fine but not for this so
immediately using the tragedy to try to
score confused and weird political
points and I've been clear when there's
a mass shooting that's a good time to
talk about mass shootings and gun safety
that's not what I'm faulting Donald
Trump for what I'm faulting him for is
trying to use this to first of all brag
about things for which he really
deserves no credit and secondly
confusion it's total confusion as to
what he believes the solutions are to
the problem that were faced with number
one he mentions Chuck Schumer Chuck
Schumer even Jeff Flake said Chuck
Schumer was one of many people involved
in the passage of that visa program Jeff
Flake also said back in 2013 we had a
bipartisan proposal to do away with this
particular program that was never made
law and it's both Republicans and
Democrats that are to blame and of
course with most of Trump's statements
there's always something or a lot
missing and in this case it's that you
still vet people who come to the United
States on this particular visa program
the selection is via lottery but you're
not exempt from vetting just because
you've been selected for a possible visa
in a lottery and the the distraction
that is the
I believe is working for many many
trumpets because they are tuning into
Fox News they are watching Breitbart or
reading Breitbart and watching Infowars
etc and it is a total misdirection
campaign and by the way also taking
attention away from the growing scandal
of Trump russia-related indictments but
that's another story which we will talk
about this incident absolutely horrible
and to be a hundred percent clear none
of what Donald Trump so far has either
attempted to enact or enacted via
executive order or proposed or suggested
during the campaign or as president
would actually have done anything to
prevent this particular attack it's a
different conversation when we should be
having but it's a different conversation
than the one that Donald Trump wants to
have the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership